we made bets NC State was in the
Pop-Tarts bowl and they lost and
Carolina was in the Duke's Mayo bowl and
they lost and our bet was if both teams
lose their bowl then Isaiah has to eat a
poptart covered in Duke's Mayo yes there
we go get a good take the other one
spread it in there really good oh a
little more than that yeah actually I'm
actually kind of interested what it
tastes like so Sebastian will you have
me that other half is it the Pop-Tart
that's nasty or is it is it the May Mayo
that's nasty the
mayonnaise and a John Reef approves now
I do love
mayonnaise so when I bit into this
prepared for it to be a weird
thing I mean I could do this